esta es una cita por un físico químico
como un comentario sobre uno de los
resultados en sus experimentos él dijo
que su experimento fue como si disparara
a un proyectil de 15 pulgadas a un papel
absorbente papel que después regresa y
te golpea hablemos de su experimento y
de lo que hizo hasta ese momento
rutherford había investigado mucho sobre
radioactividad era amigo de marie curie
y de su esposo pierre también había
hecho muchos estudios observando
diferentes tipos de reactividad sobre
todo estaba muy interesado en las
partículas alfa
tenía curiosidad sobre las partículas
alfa que bueno hasta ese momento él no
sabía que eran pero nosotros sabemos que
son núcleos de helio dos más eso
significa que en el núcleo tenemos dos
protones y también tenemos dos neutrones
pero no tenemos electrones por eso tiene
una carga dos más entonces primero
rutherford tomó un poco de radio y lo
puso en una caja y esta caja tenía un
hueco muy pequeño en uno de los lados
así las partículas radioactivas alfa
podían salir de la caja en la dirección
que él quisiera y después él disparó las
partículas alfa hacia una lámina de oro
una lámina de oro muy delgada
él hacía este experimento porque estaba
muy interesado en ver si podía aprender
un poco más sobre la estructura del
átomo entonces regresando a la cita
podríamos decir que las partículas alfa
son balas que salen de nuestra pistola
de partículas alfa y la lámina de oro es
nuestro papel absorbente
entonces tenemos todas estas partículas
alfa muy rápidas y sólidas que son
disparadas pero porque router for
esperaba que eso pasara porque pensaría
que las partículas alfa viajarían
únicamente hacia la lámina de oro bueno
pues en ese momento router for estaba
probando el modelo del pudding de pases
esto es muy al inicio de la historia en
donde si nosotros fuéramos científicos
de la época sabríamos que jj thompson
otro físico acababa de descubrir los
electrones entonces hasta ese momento
sabíamos que el átomo tiene unas
partículas en él que son muy muy
pequeñas incluso menos que el 1% de la
masa de un átomo de hidrógeno mucho más
pequeñas que un átomo y también
sabríamos que están cargadas
negativamente
estos son los electrones actualmente
sabemos que son electrones pero en ese
tiempo jj thomson supo que existían los
electrones basándose en los resultados
de sus experimentos con sus resultados
él propuso que un átomo se ve como un
pudín de pasas
si no saben que es un pudín de pasas
porque no son británicos o simplemente
no les gustan los postres imaginen que
esto se parece a una galleta con chispas
de chocolate entonces tenemos estas
pequeñas partículas cargadas
negativamente que están atrapadas
adentro de lato pero la mayor parte del
átomo está hecha de una especie de sopa
cargada positivamente y eso es porque en
gran parte el átomo tiene que ser neutro
los científicos sabían que los átomos
eran neutros así que debía existir algo
ahí que cancelará la carga negativa de
los electrones ahora como rutherford
pensaba que así se veían los átomos de
oro pudo predecir matemáticamente lo que
harían las partículas alfa y lo que
predijo fue que se movería con esta
trayectoria incluso podemos usar
ecuaciones físicas para analizar el
campo eléctrico que es generado por esta
sopa
positivamente pero resulta que como la
carga está distribuida por todo el átomo
el campo es muy débil entonces él pensó
que todas las partículas se movería en
esta dirección y quizá de vez en cuando
algunas se desviaría un poco dependiendo
de por dónde pasará la partícula alfa
así que él pensó que podría existir una
ligera desviación pero en general las
partículas se moverían derecho aunque
bueno creo que nos podemos adelantar un
poco porque ya sabemos que en realidad
no ocurrió todo lo que él esperaba pero
exactamente qué fue lo que vio
rutherford bueno al disparar las
partículas alfa observó que la mayoría
de las partículas pasaron a través justo
como él esperaba de hecho la mayoría de
las partículas pasaron a través pero
unas cuantas se desviaron un poco a lo
mejor menos de un grado lo suficiente
para poder verlas pero si él no hubiera
tenido tanta
o ciudad como químico tal vez aún ahora
pensaríamos que así es como se ve un
átomo
afortunadamente rutherford fue muy
cuidadoso y también pensó en que quizás
sería interesante detectar si las
partículas llegaban no sólo aquí él no
sólo puso un detector aquí sino que se
le ocurrió poner un detector en todo
alrededor
casi todo alrededor dejando un espacio
para que las partículas alfa pudieran
entrar y fue muy cuidadoso porque
realmente él no esperaba ver algo por
aquí o por acá solamente esperaba ver
algo aquí pero al final resultó que por
cada partícula alfa entre 20.000 o algún
número muy pequeño como ese supongamos
que por cada una entre 20 mil partículas
alfa él observó que las partículas
golpeaban la lámina de oro y rebotaba
que lo cono eso es justamente lo que no
esperaríamos cuando golpeamos un papel
absorbente con una bala y bueno no creo
que lo primero que hiciera rutherford
fuera decir esto es muy loco acabamos de
ganar un premio nobel no más bien estoy
segura que pensó esto es muy raro y
probablemente revisó los resultados de
su experimento y trató de repetirlo
revisando todo para asegurarse de que
nada estaba mal y al fin
si algo estaba ocurriendo una de cada
20.000 partículas alfa era real pero qué
significa eso bueno eso significa que
necesitábamos un nuevo modelo atómico
porque de alguna manera tenía que
explicar que una fracción muy pequeña de
las partículas alfa estaba rebotando
pero como lo hizo bueno él supo que
había algo en el átomo que era muy
pequeño
solito
y cargado positivamente
él sabía que tenía que ser muy pequeño
porque no muchas partículas alfa
interactuaban con él la mayoría pasaba a
través de la lámina también supo que
tenía que ser sólido y cargado
positivamente porque bueno los
electrones son muy pequeños y la mayoría
de las partículas pasaban a través así
que con lo que fuera que interactuaban
estas partículas tenía que ser muy
pequeño pero muy sólido así es cómo
rebotaban así que rutherford hizo un
nuevo modelo atómico que incorporaba
estos puntos él dijo que existía algo
aquí con estas propiedades ahora lo
conocemos como núcleo
el núcleo es muy pequeño de hecho
rutherford pudo calcular aproximadamente
qué tan grande era basándose en cuántas
partículas alfa lo golpeaba y dijo que
aproximadamente era de una fracción
igual a 1 entre 10.000 del volumen del
átomo entonces ya sabemos que tenemos un
núcleo que está cargado positivamente y
que es muy pequeño y sólido y también
tenemos a los electrones pero qué pasa
con el resto del átomo bueno si nos
basamos en esto el resto del átomo son
espacios vacíos
como los electrones son muy pequeños y
el núcleo solo ocupa una pequeñísima
fracción el resto no tiene nada lo cual
es un poco loco no así que basándose en
este modelo rutherford pudo explicar sus
resultados pudo explicar que la mayoría
de las partículas alfa pasaban a través
del átomo pero que algunas veces una
partícula alfa pasaba muy cerca del
núcleo con lo que se desviaba un poco
pero también muy rara vez una partícula
alfa chocaba con el núcleo y rebotaba
porque el núcleo es muy denso y está
cargado positivamente así que repele las
partículas alfa que también están
cargadas positivamente a este modelo no
recuerdo si fue rutherford quien le puso
el nombre pero este es el modelo nuclear
modelo nuclear y observen que es muy
parecido a la imagen moderna del átomo
que la mayoría conocemos pero todavía
hay muchas preguntas que aún no son
respondidas aquí como por ejemplo qué
están haciendo los electrones o dónde
están dónde están los electrones
pero bueno como rutherford propuso este
nuevo modelo otros científicos pudieron
diseñar nuevos experimentos para
probarlo y no mucho después de eso se
pudo obtener una muy buena imagen de lo
que ocurre a nivel atómico